okay so I'm playing highest rated player
I've played so far play a Sicilian play
a different line I want to play a dragon
if he lets me please don't play rustling
oh oh he plays with something mo I have
to blame Fabiano for this for
popularizing the rustle emo I think I'll
play you six which is not a move that
was played at all in the World
Championship match
but it's only move I've studied in this
line now I'll play 94 lady 4 is an
interesting move if while I light some
opening principle they move the same
piece twice but I'm trying to attack
stuff and one of the points with 94 is
that this line is not supposed to be
good for white because of the move Queen
g5 and this is a fork and believe
White's just losing a pawn I've had this
before but it's been a while it's not
too many people play exactly this line
and fall into it but I think it's still
going to be playable for lights you just
take the pawn maybe you like get some
compensation Johanna tries with a raid
thanks Johanna shout-out to Joanna
streaming earlier streaming crazy-house
earlier it's been a lot of crazy house
lately yeah I think I'll take the pawn
because what else to do and now the
knight is tied down to the rook so White
has no time to take this pawn and
meanwhile I'm just up to pawns this
looks like a great position because the
bishop is on d3 which blocks the pawn
which blocks a bishop
okay so c3 well first thing that comes
to mind is Bishop c5 because f2 looks
really juicy if there should c5 takes
takes and I can't take because it's
still tied down meanwhile f2 could be a
problem and if there should c5 rook
takes here I take here and I'm
threatening enough to again let's do it
yeah I'm pretty sure there is a better
way to play this for whites but I forgot
how where do we go
don't recall ever seeing a viewer from
Puerto Rico welcome to the stream yeah
it's very possible Knight g3 was better
at some points okay b4 interesting move
taking the bishop I mean I want to take
care of but it loses a piece let's move
back White's gonna play c4 hmm-hmm I
have to do it
yeah the one sort of good thing for
white about this position even though
White's down to pawns is that it it's a
bit chaotic and there are ways for white
today come back and get compensation I
give in here I have two things to worry
about my g7 pawn and the threat of c5
winning d4 so do I defend I mean Queen
e5 defends both things but it looks way
too agree lady six give away g7 I like
the move 97 97 at rook takes g7 I have
mates in East 6 419 g6 chopping the rook
and if 97 c5 Bishop here the Knights
still can't take as a rook is hanging so
let's do it
and I'm developing it so c5 have to do
this and there might be some goal like
very soon of playing Knight g6 to h4 to
f3 if this were a crazy house I would
love to just drop a knight on f3 right
away but I have to be patience have to
follow the rules so the pawns attacks
twice
I can play e5 lots of Bishop though so
what about this takes and then they left
for attacking and attacking let's do it
as I don't see how White's going to cope
with night afore it looks looks
difficult because the bishops undefended
and the night is tied down so I think
this is a monster threat not to mention
I still have ideas of this night h4
maneuver also 95 I can't draw airless I
want to draw arrows because this is so
fun nail worthy like there's so many
night moves to attack like squares and
pieces and deflect White's pieces from
defending other white pieces now this is
some pretty thumbnail worthy one more
you know it sure takes d4 is probably a
blunder okay so Queen c2 actually looks
reasonable wants to queenside castle but
then I wouldn't have to just keep
winning more pawns yeah the problem is
that the King kind of slips away
looking at 95 queenside castling and
then queen h3 but then there's rook g3
maybe now it's time for a five could
also play Knight f4 queenside castling
and take on e 2 and then take on f2 and
I keep initiative because I attack you -
I think I'll do that
it's greedy but it winds up on
I can still decide if I want to take on
d-32 or take on f2 first
this feels very greedy but the bishops
attacked
there should be five coming let's do it
I'm not three pawns I've not lost a
single pawn yet I have two connected
passers but White has three hath open
files on the Kings side yeah the more
pawns you lose the more files you gain
Queen d3 three all about that move I
mean my queen should not be getting
trapped so I always have Queen h4 so I
guess Bishop e5 defending both pawns
I mean odds are White's probably gonna
win a pawn back like rook DF one Queen
h4 Bishop takes d4 how bad is that that
could be pretty bad actually
I could play Queen h2 though the Queen's
tied down to defending bishop we need to
my work h1i of Queens III
I mean the problem for me currently I
have none of these pieces in the game
when White has basically all of the
pieces in the game so I would like to
play b6 at some points get some
initiative develop my Bishop harass the
White King that could take some time
okay here I would like to Queen trillion
this is the only move you work out three
might be coming in Queen g6
Queen g5 choices choices Queen g5 could
be slightly better
and go play queen g5 with more options
defends the bishop so after Bishop takes
d4 I might not even take like I might go
for b6 right away you have to watch out
for time could take and then go for d6
Oh
but there's Ritchie one ideas that's
actually kind of scary so what do I do
now I might be being punished for my
greed takes takes e5 maybe 26 27
maybe go for a six takes takes off six
doesn't look right though this looks
very shaky
maybe t6 takes and then like Bishop d7
[Music]
it's really wrong don't know what to do
here
but there's some tactic to take and play
queen g2 being extra greedy I might do
that because I don't see what else to do
queen g2 that if it forces rook e1 that
would be a great sign just look so wrong
I mean I'm so long time life to do
something there's nothing developed
except my queen and it's on g2 it's
about to get trapped somehow probably
blame all three pawns
I have to expect rocky one maybe be six
now I have to do something to come back
and develop I would much rather be white
in this position I think but the
Bishop's tied down like white is a
little bit stuck the bishops tied down
to the truck and this rook is tied down
to the bishop and for the time being
things are defended so work up to is
logical I could take first maybe I'll
take first I'd be happy with the Queen
trade
and I'll probably might just slipped
let's put it in this hopefully that's
better
I'll probably put the Quinn on g5 g or
queen g3 maybe queen g3 pinning the rook
to the brook I just have to move quickly
I want to play queen a3
I've disobeyed so many principals in the
opening I have moved my queen pretty
much like half of the game so far
neglecting developing my pieces just
going after clones but maybe it's paying
off queen a3 check rook b8 come in who's
gonna make who first b8 Yolo I just want
to play rook b1 and made them before he
meets me rook me one should be a threat
I always have f6 to to try and defend
maybe
Bishop c4 Wow so rook b1 gotta move much
quicker rook e1 we trade I have Bishop
a6 and we trade more I mean I'd be happy
with trading I'm very happy with trading
I can still legally castle you can
legally castle after move 30 rights
there's no rule against that they have
50 seconds left who I'm threatening to
win another pawn me too I feel like
you're just grabbing pawns all over the
place we should remove that
okay now castling and my king is safe
ooh free pawn next move while castle I'm
up for pawns no I can't count I'm only
up three plums that's a lot of pawns he
wants to meet me let's play am I losing
this oh no I forgot about that move I
have to play I guess that I'm giving
back a pawn it hurts but it's necessary
least I have Queen f7
I have 28 seconds there's no increments
so I can't gain time as Queen stay on
the board maybe I can meet him more
quickly I want to play f5 it's Queen d6
probably f5 if we trade that I put the
rook on AIDS and start pushing
okay so we trade yeah rooks belong
behind pass pawns
he's gonna play rook a six and just
blockade but this is where the two
connected pastors come into play so I'll
push these pawns well let's start with
that maybe I'll give up the a pawn hmm
what's going on here I push too far or
did he the rook can't come back but
maybe it's a race but I'm winning the
race and it's a sub from the ultimate
edge thanks for the sub in nineteen
seconds should be enough to win this
it's such a weird game I think Brooke
takes d7 was a blunder he should have
played the group a 100k won maybe even
White's better because he can win the H
pawn
okay so now I have to use some technique
let's try and attack the D pawn with the
King to the center another sub don't
distract me though okay no it's gonna be
time to start winning pawns rook takes
e4 to me and maybe it would be a mistake
because King d3 but now it should be
easy win
that's probably possible to win this
without wasting another second the other
goal is not to get below 11 seconds oh
that would have been stalemates if I hit
play King afore and he played King h3 ok
let's not still mean them
check
you used a bit too much time but I still
have enough time
okay I did it yes okay I was a difficult
game but I was up material pretty much
the whole game I want to pawn and then
another pawn and then another pawn at
some point I feel like whites should
have been much better like around here I
was feeling very bad but somehow queen
g2 kind of worked it's such a greedy
move
but if Ricky won this horse then it was
worth it well I take that pawn again I
mean it was tasty at the time if I would
take it again I don't know depends how
hungry I would be I'm pretty full after
this game Queen g3 was useful moved to
yeah it would be interesting to see like
how many Queen moves I played like the
first 25 moves I maybe like 30 to 40
percent okay good game back to
tournament if people want to use stock
fish to analyze that feel free